thank you very much Andy all right well
thank you all for attending it's a real
honor and pleasure to be here I hope
you'll find this interesting first a few
words about myself I got my career
started back in the 80s at Los Alamos
the picture of Los Alamos National
Laboratories so that was a lot of fun
worked on craze and connection machines
and computers like that which of course
you know the cell phone you carry around
in your pocket is a lot more powerful
than those machines those machines were
my claim to fame is that it's 17 years
at Microsoft I was book eights his
technology advisor for three and a half
years I ran the Microsoft advertising
division and I was CTO for Microsoft
online and after that I did I was part
of the management team at AOL probably
turnaround team when it spun out again
and what was a public company so a CTO I
ran about a third of the company and
these days I'm working on cybersecurity
with my new company probably worse and
so we're working in this field of moving
target defense as well so we think about
cyber security I want to walk you
through a story here of Sun Tzu Einstein
to be named gentleman in zombies and
they all relate if you can believe that
and so hopefully I will by the end of
this talk I will have you convinced that
all these four four people they all tie
together in a very coherent way so start
with Sun Tzu so if you're not familiar
with him
a very very famous basically military
tactician from China from you know
hundreds of years ago and he wrote a
very famous book called the art of war
and there's a lot of wisdom in
of war and one of the chief things that
he advocated is don't do full-on frontal
attacks find out where your enemy is
weak it's right there
and instead of striking when your enemy
is strong so try to basically practice
asymmetric warfare and that's sort of a
very fundamental concept and this has
been around with you know human history
now for thousands of years so I think
about this idea of asymmetric warfare
and you apply it to computers are we
weak anywhere I mean it's pretty much
every week now you see that some
somebody getting hacked right now
Capital One Anthem Blue Cross premiere
blue cross Sony Home Depot target Office
of Personnel Management Democratic
National Committee I mean these things
go on and on and on and on and on I'm
not going to bore you with all the
details you can read easily in the
papers just the stats we got to kind of
look at it and say what the heck is
going on well for the uninitiated what's
going on is people are making a lot of
money doing this the sophistication of
sort of the whole cyber cyber attack
world it's completely been gone hard and
a horizontal marketplace if you're
familiar that from Clayton Christensen
there were literally specialist
companies that do nothing but create
attacks or find bugs and create exploits
there's other companies that do nothing
but just take over computers and then
resell them on the black market or
they'll take over passwords and try to
find passwords and these sell those and
so it's gotten very very specialized and
there are a lot of different players in
this space you know some of the stuff
you hear a lot about these days in the
news of course is Russia and China for
sure that nation-state level level
attacks but then going down from the
nation-states you know the China Russia
I ran so forth you have essentially you
know organized crime I think because if
you can steal a credit card number you
can steal medical information you could
steal somebody's personal identity and
go go get steal their tax refund for
example you can make money doing this
and then sort of stepping down from
there and you basically have you know
your terrorists are doing it just to
cause trouble and then you've got your
what are commonly referred to as script
kiddies basically the folks who are
doing this for you know sort of fame and
glory on their own but they don't really
have a big agenda but one of the things
that's really interesting is just how
pervasive the tools can become so maybe
just quick show of hands anybody in here
owned a tank okay there's one was that
oh well I like Schwarzenegger has got
one so okay do you own a nuclear weapon
okay
so for anybody on the video since you
can't see the lack of hands nobody in
here has a tank or a nuclear weapon
because it's sort of traditional you
know arms control
you know the weapons that are used by
countries you know tanks and general
planes and aircraft carriers and nuclear
missiles those are basically controlled
you just can't go and buy an aircraft
carrier or a tank as a private citizen
certainly not one that's you know
functioning but in computers what's a
what's a nation-state military-grade you
know virus or malware just encode and if
you look at attacks like wanna cry for
those of you that aren't familiar wanna
cry was the attack they hit windows
attack the file system basically bricked
you know couple million Windows
computers was quite a quite a bad attack
gave a lot of trouble to the mayor
the shipping line if you look at that
particular virus if it had two parts to
it I personally had a chance to study
the code one part of it was and bluntly
written by a kid it was sloppy the whole
ransomware part and sloppy sloppy sloppy
the part that actually was the exploit
that got into the Windows computer that
was genius level code I'm making all the
ethics of it but whoever wrote that was
really really smart it was extremely
well commented in perfect English I'm
gonna let that stand for what it is but
you know somebody was a professional
wrote that that was written by a
nation-state and yet it finds its way
into the hands of you know a quote
fifteen-year-old and caused a lot of
trouble because we're basically in this
role today where it is cheaper to attack
than it is to defend right because I can
get my hands on the cyber equivalent of
tanks and aircraft carriers and nuclear
weapons just as an individual or as a
terrorist organization or as part of an
organized criminal gang or what-have-you
I can get the same tools that no nations
are using it's just software so if we
want to dig into why that is go to our
second second person in our lineup Alan
Turing very famous British computer
scientist one of the very first and he
formulated something called the halting
problem and since I know there are a
number of about computer science folks
in the audience here I'm going to skip
the math and I'm going to abuse the
actual formulation of the halting
problem and go with a more practical
definition which is basically that all
software is going to have bugs if you
have any non-trivial piece of software
there's no way to prove that it is
unhackable at least with our current
understanding
technology and so if all software has
bugs that gives an attacker something to
to exploit and if you look at you know
this is for prevalence of bugs there's
actually a lot of bugs out there this
this is something my company puts out
but it is completely open-source it
something call the open Linux weakness
report and what we've done is taken a
static code analyzer there's essentially
spell check code so what we done is
taken essentially the static code
analyzers these are essentially spell
checkers for software they find bugs and
in my company we have over 8.8 billion
lines of Linux and open source code that
we apply our defense technologies to so
we simply ran these these analytics
tools over eight billion lines of code
and not surprisingly we literally find
millions of unpatched bugs millions of
bugs this is not too shocking because
you have a lot of you know Linux is
written in C C++ you know Microsoft
Windows is written in C and C++ and a
lot of those bugs or pointer bugs memory
memory type bugs because you have the C
programming language
and what's fascinating is even with
Linux even you have version you know say
two years ago might have a million bugs
the version the next year sometimes has
more and sometimes has less so so it's
like every time you fix a bug you put
another one in it's sort of this not
never-ending you know whack-a-mole game
of trying to fix bugs and Linux now the
Linux data we have because it's open
source and we're able to share that but
I can assure you that the proprietary
operating systems have just as many
issues I used to be an engineer on
Windows and Windows does not magically
immune from from pointer bugs either
right so this is just a fundamental
problem the software that we're using in
depending on these days just has lots
and lots of bugs and can we possibly
patch them fast enough they're just sort
of no way and you think about sort of
our current you know mentality if you
will to cyber defense it's really one of
you know get those patches out I know
and pretty much today Apple Microsoft
and the Linux community everybody does
it they say hope there's an emergency
security patch you better go do it and
yes you should because now the attackers
know about the bug too but nobody can
patch fast enough we're very much in a
paradigm today of having a reactive
approach to cyber security
it's patch more do even fancier machine
learning on the analytics to figure out
that somebody hacked you and
fundamentally you sort of have to ask
that question is that really working for
us you know I don't want to pick on any
particular company but if you look at
Equifax that was a pretty bad hack you
know a couple hundred million records
lost fire I know the cybersecurity
company they had a case study of how
awesome their cybersecurity was and
Equifax now that's been taken down off
the web by the way you can't find it
anymore you got to go to the to the
Internet Archive or the Wayback Machine
to get it but you know but they had a
case study of how good it was and look
you know fireEye's are perfectly you
know good firewall product you bought it
at AOL you know it's no no secret there
you know and for what it does it does a
good job but what it doesn't do is stop
attackers and it doesn't stop any
serious attacker and so we're kind of in
this world today of sort of applying the
same reactive philosophy over and over
over again and expecting it to change
and my claim is it's not going to change
and this is where the zombies come in so
the fundamental issue is basically the
combination of zombies and Alan Turing
so everything has bugs it's another
question is what is the payoff for
exploiting a bug well in today's world
software's a monoculture if I learn how
to hack Windows I can take over a
billion computers but on how to hack
Linux I can take over five billion or
more computers you have ten billion if
you include all the devices out there
that's pretty compelling doesn't really
doesn't really bother me if I've got to
spend a lot of time learning how to hack
something or spend a lot of effort or
really poke at it or do these really
exotic you know memory based attacks
from worried about little gadgets and
things like that I want explain those
shortly who cares I get a billion
computers right huge payoff so if we
want to fundamentally solve this problem
well we know mathematically we can't fix
the bugs so we can't solve the root root
cause that there's bugs that can we
solve the economic root cause which is
the payoff on an attack and that's the
fundamental thesis behind an idea called
moving target defense this is an
academic idea that's been around for
about you know thirty years or so I
think is the earliest paper I recall
reading reading about it and it's just
now coming to the forefront of being
widely adopted and the fundamental
thesis of moving target defense is about
changing the economics on the payoff
right it doesn't say we can fix all the
bugs it says what if we made it really
really hard to exploit the bugs and if
you have a bug we've got to exploit it
individually every time so instead of a
run once break every word
type world it becomes a run once break
once type world and so it's about you
know creating dynamism and diversity in
the environment now this isn't a
terribly shocking idea but look around
the room here and see a lot of different
a lot of different folks I imagine if
every human had the same DNA right if we
all had the same DNA as if we are clones
of each other as a species we would have
been wiped out ages ago right by you
know Spanish food we banach plague
zombie apocalypse I told you zombies
would come in here somewhere
you know because we just would like this
this first time something went wrong
we'd all be affected by it so our
genetic diversity gives us strength and
resilience as a species and so what if
we applied that same idea of diversity
to software instead of every copy of
Windows being the same what if we can
make every us one of them unique again
that's the idea of moving target defense
and it applies sort of top to bottom
across the stack you have moving target
defense ideas in the infrastructure
layer like at your networking layer this
whole idea of polymorphic networks where
the actual configuration of the network
is constantly changing the IP addresses
where things reside is constantly
changing so if you're just trying to
find and discover a service that knows
maybe storing the credit card data that
can be very very hard to do if the if
the entire network topology is
constantly changing you can do the same
idea to the binaries on the computers
themselves from the kernel to your
middleware to to the applications you
can actually make the software on on the
system at that binary level completely
dynamic and have literally the ones and
zeroes the binaries continuously
changing to go defeat any kind
- no memory-based attack you can do the
same thing with all going one level up
the stack you can do the same thing with
all of your script engines whether it's
like a sequel server or PHP or
JavaScript or something you can
literally create unique dynamically
create unique scripting languages such
that that traditional script injection
type of attack won't work and you know
at the at the highest level when you
have things like for authentication are
things like multi-factor authentication
right you notice I think of it it's not
very big compilation or necessarily
think of it as a moving target defense
but you can literally go to the dark web
these days and buy databases of billions
of passwords and it's super cheap and if
your password is in that database it's
game over because it's very very easy
for an attacker to you know go to that
database and use that password so think
about a password as a static defense
it's one secret and once it's out your
your over and instead the multi-factor
authentication is a constantly changing
secret right it's one number used once
now of course there are ways to hack
sort of the current cell phone based
multi-factor authentication system so
I'm not trying to claim that this is the
panacea for all authentication type type
attacks but if you think about it from
the point of view of changing the
economics you go from the world in which
I can take over
anybody that has one of a billion
passwords in literally a second and
that's super easy - one where the only
way I can I shouldn't say the only way
but the common way for me to break
multi-factor authentication is to have a
person go full enough verizon fake up
that person if they got my target and so
doing it cellphone transfer and so forth
and get the number moved over that's
expensive right that's not being done in
seconds across a billion different
accounts and so again it's all about
changing the changing the economics so
if we look at it from the point of view
of the software itself one of the
fascinating things is that if you look
at the attacks in IBM IBM's pony money
Institute did the study seventy-seven
percent of all of the successful attacks
last year were so-called violence of
taxis memory based attacks and it spans
the range it was the Office of Personnel
Management hacked which basically
anybody that had anything to do with the
government you know about this one cuz
you had your records stolen it was the
wanna cry attack it was a Democrat
National Committee email server attack
it was that both act so all these
attacks were or these so-called memory
based violence attacks and they have a
very common property to them and the
sort of common theme is that the attacks
use the victim as the virus so in the
old days you know call it 90s if you
wanted to ride a virus it was really
easy you just wrote evil that eggsy you
put it on a floppy disk and trick
somebody into installing it and and you
could take over and own any dos box it
was it was pretty straightforward right
or you could just tell that into port 25
on on the email server and send any
email from anybody to anybody so no good
old days super super easy to write a
virus or do a cyberattack these days you
can't do you can't do evil that XE you
know the fire eyes in Palo Alto is and
nor
we'll do a great job of getting rid of
the the sort of the really simple stuff
so what the attackers have resorted to
because again the economics favorite is
using the victim as the virus and the
way they do that is literally using the
code that's there to be to misbehave
it's kind of like mind control so if you
take Equifax for example that was a
script injection attack where they just
literally went in and knocked over the
web server but think about that web
server that web server is supposed to be
there so it already is permissioned and
signed and has all the certs and
everything else that web server already
had permission is to talk to the
database they knew where the database
was they had the IP address it had the
right login and you had to decrypt the
data from the database and it also had
permission to send data out because
that's its job to send data oh no out
out to the customers so if I can take
over that web server and I want to steal
you know all the information out of that
database easy peasy
it's got all the right building blocks
for me and so what I need to do then is
basically trick that web server into
misbehaving and giving giving me control
and that is terribly terribly hard for
traditional cybersecurity techniques and
you're like signature scanners and and
firewalls to detect because what are you
gonna do delete the web server you can't
write there's nothing there's nothing to
delete it's it's literally misbehaving
you know right in the guts of the code
so the way that you can solve this and
address it is by changing around all
those guts and so there are polymorphic
operating systems now available for
Windows and Linux and so forth these are
becoming fairly popular I think all told
there's maybe 10 million or more servers
that are not polymorphic out there and
it's
incredibly fast it's not as widely
adopted yet as as multi-factor
authentication on phones but the idea is
very very simple you literally take the
entire stack of the operating system
from the kernel to all your drivers to
your libraries like Lib C to you middle
or pieces like a web server or what have
you and you literally make them unique
at the binary level on each and every
server and if you make them unique
then what you're able to do is foil foil
the attacks and let me explain how that
works all right if I go off and this
still working yes this one I do need to
and you need to walk for so this is the
specter attack I agreed from a respecter
or is that so inspector was a class of a
cyber attacks found by Google that
basically effect Intel and AMD chips and
it basically used a flaw in the chip to
let somebody take over the kernel and
get full control of a computer so in a
very simple sense and the way that it
works is in the victim and the attacker
I am able to know exactly the set of
instruction sequences that that I'm
going to see and so in the spectres case
what it does is a Trixie and the
instruction prefetch pipeline of the
chip and as the attacker what I want to
do is okay I know my victim for
controlling access or getting the credit
card or you know whatever piece I want
to get to I know exactly where that code
is I can inspect it and then we get the
sequence the exact sequence of assembly
instructions and I'm going to write my
own program that has that exact same
sequence of instructions and I'm going
to trick the instruction pipeline or
pipeline of the chip to start executing
kernel code of my own design because
I've now told it go pre
all these instructions and so it ended
up making a very very effective
technique to break out of user mode into
the kernel and again it works only
because I know exactly what to expect
you go to a polymorphic operating system
when you change around all those
binaries you're using different
registers different sequence of
instructions and it's different on every
on every computer every server and some
of the more advanced installations it
literally changes every system call so
if your binaries are constantly changing
the attacker doesn't really know what's
there and if they don't know it's there
it becomes very very costly for them to
figure out which or sort of reuse those
existing components and they'll have to
resort to different means to attack and
that's what what a polymorphic operating
system will do I guess I'm gonna do
questions at the end but um but if
anybody has questions feel free to ask
in the middle it's always a lot more fun
that way makes sense so foreign kind of
that binary binary diversification so if
you go up the stack to the the script
engines if you think about the classic
script injection attack we say sequel
injection attack up in Seattle where I
live they've now over the last decade
they've introduced toll roads across the
bridge and a few other places and these
toll roads work on a camera so we'll
take a camera and scan your license
plate I have not done this but I am
sorely tempted to go get one of those
custom license plates and have it be
semicolon drop table so by the laughter
I think most people know exactly what's
going to happen at that point
look I haven't done that turns out it's
one character too many verses Washington
state law so I'd have to think of a
different different injection attack but
that's the classic class of thing is
that you know if if there is a bug in
somebody's handling of a sequel queries
and they don't do the you know sort of
user supplied data concatenation with
the sequel commands correctly then if
your last name becomes drop table or
something like that you could end up
causing a lot of havoc to the database
but that only works if you know what the
sequel language is drop means something
in sequel from means something where
means something cable means something
well what if it wasn't drop anymore what
if it was drop one two three or X Y X Y
Z four five six was really the drop
command what if we actually just
dynamically changed the programming
language of these different script
engines and so I have an example here of
PHP where you know it's done done
exactly like this and the PHP polish
scripting is fully open source but it
literally changes not only the keywords
of the language but also the grammar I
just have keywords up on the slides
that's the easiest to get if you
continuously change these things then it
becomes very very hard for somebody to
do a mass attack there was a really bad
probably the worst script injection
attack I'm familiar with is one called
Drupal get and it was about two years
ago it might be three years ago now but
it was attacking a bug in the PHP bug
and the Drupal content management system
it literally took down about a third of
the world's websites within hours if you
didn't get your patch up within eight
hours your website was taken over I was
a very very nasty script injection bug
and the reason those work is because I
could write my own nasty
PHP code and it was going to work on
tens of millions of websites but imagine
if I had to write a unique I had to go
discover and do some you know go break
into somebody's lab and go learn exactly
what what flavour of PHP they were doing
and I had to do that ten million times
there never would have been a Drupal
gedan that's the whole thesis behind
Nepali scripting again it's all about
changing the economics of the attacks
and so if I sort of take this moving
target defense idea and pop it up pop it
up a level there's an overall movement
these days in so the leading edge
cybersecurity circles called agile
security and the whole idea is to take
the dynamism and diversity of moving
target defense as a sort of fundamental
philosophy and then just to ask the
question well what else do we need to
have a completely thorough and robust
cyber security you know cyber security
program and so the diversity and
dynamism we spoke about a lot another
very simple idea that is surprisingly
not done often is minimalism so if we
think about anybody running Microsoft
Windows in in the cloud any chance
sure like just with Azure just use
Windows Server and Windows Server is
about 20 gigabytes it includes support
for floppy disks you can play fortnight
on it when's the last time anybody stuck
a floppy disk into a cloud server
like never
but that code is there and it just
becomes yet another attack point all
right we talked about wanna cry earlier
that attacked
smv file system nobodies use the SMB
file system and ages this is like the
1980s early 90s file system for network
sharing and windows it's still there and
because it's there and was you know
basically it was it was a source of
attack and so we're a lot of folks you
know if we're kind of on a leading edge
are doing these days is saying you know
what if I'm gonna be running something
let me run the exact minimal thing I
need to do and so there's a version of
Linux called Alpine Linux there's a
bunch of other ones tiny core and so
forth a bunch of core or whatnot but
Alpine is kind of a sort of popular one
used by docker it's a 20 megabyte
version so it's a 20 megabyte web server
not a not a 20 gigabyte you know web
host and it does not include support for
a floppy drive floppy disks and things
like that you can add it if you really
need it
but by default is a teeny tiny operating
system so that whole idea of minimalism
is just reduce your surface area have
less things to attack because like we've
talked about before there will be bugs
right and I'd rather have 20 megabytes
of bugs versus 20 gigabytes of bugs it
just for a simple map repeatable is
another another idea of this idea of
what's the what's sort of the most
common source of errors in any of our
systems today yeah people yeah the whole
the whole meatspace thing is just
problematic but people make a lot of
mistakes and if you can automate your
processes and make them a lot more
repeatable and predictable you can get
rid of a lot of sources of human error I
mentioned in the beginning of my my
background was part of my background is
being CTO for Microsoft online so I did
that in the early early era of Microsoft
getting into
to online services in a big way
obviously now no cloud and all that is
kind of the big thing for Microsoft but
back in the day it wasn't and we we sort
of applied traditional windows
engineering methodologies to running
online services and so our update
process because sometimes take us over a
month a month just to update all of our
all of our servers and needs to say it
was it was very right manual we'd set up
could we commandeer a conference room
and put a little post-its of like all
the different steps different people are
supposed to do you know this operator
had to go up upgrade this particular
machine at this particular sequence and
I mean we got it done but yeah we made a
lot of mistakes all the time and it took
a while to to get the whole thing ironed
out and these days is pretty common to
for any of the major online cloud
services to be shipping and updating
many times a day so we've gone from I
used to take them on to you know
literally minutes now validation is this
idea of just checking your stuff all
right spoke about the static code
analyzers maybe by show of hands how
many anybody still writing code these
days or running a team this writing code
do you all use a set of code elements
and author of any kind okay I have one
yes and one no budget does okay good
just sort of think about like you
wouldn't dream of writing an email to
your boss without running it through a
spell checker right yet how many how
many organizations out there
run run static code analyzers mean spell
check if you actually look at the static
code analyzer market you know Cemil and
fortify those yes sir
yes that's uh that actually gets to a
concept called polymorphic email which I
I don't have a slide on oh yeah
so uh yeah the comment from the from no
no no it's great the comment was if your
if your boss knows that you frequently
misspelled and maybe this Billings are
useful because it becomes a signature
for yourself but outside of that maybe
when you go interview you're not gonna
you're not gonna do them spellings yes
sir exactly they're completely built-in
but for programmers they're not built-in
not yet anyway Microsoft just bought
some old which is one of the better
static code analyzers so perhaps they're
going to integrate it individual studio
great videos but the hope the whole
point of validation is not that not that
these tools are perfect but like if you
have them use them maybe you don't have
them they're probably available and get
them because why not there's they're
relatively inexpensive and they're easy
to use and they will catch mistakes
encryption is another hopefully a fairly
obvious point that folks heard of
Cambridge analytical and Facebook
it's my I don't know this might be being
commenting on this in Silicon Valley but
was that a hack so for those that don't
know Cambridge analytic is the current
controversy around a particular company
called Cambridge analytic misusing
people's data from Facebook and
sometimes in the press you'll see it
called you know they they hacked
Facebook no no if you put your data on
Facebook it's publicly available and
Facebook's business model sucks Prada
stations to the contrary is to make
money on your data No however many
transformations they do fundamentally
Facebook makes money on your day
and your data is public so if you want
your data to be public it's fine but
don't have any illusions that what you
post to Facebook is somehow private and
so you know encryption is just another
way of saying if you want your data to
be public but it on Facebook if you
don't want it to be public then encrypt
it and do a good job managing your keys
and you know basically trying to keep it
out of the hands of people that you
don't want to have see yet the final
idea of all this is compartmentalization
anybody heard of Ed Snowden yeah so Ed
Snowden is the contractor who worked for
Booz Allen for on behalf of the NSA and
he stole a bunch of stuff and you know
leaked it to the press and to the
Russians and basically caused a bit of
brouhaha it's kind of fascinating I
personally have the privilege of doing a
lot of work with the government and I
can I can attest they they spend a lot
of effort with classification and who
can know what and doing background
checks and polygraph checks and all
kinds of stuff and so you think about
the NSA they go to all this trouble and
all this no pomp and circumstance of
like secret pop secret and secure
compartmentalized and special access
programs and a bunch of other acronyms
that you're not even allowed to talk
about and and then they give this
20-something year old kid in Hawaii
system minister privileges well not a
lot of different religions in the world
but if you're in computers the system
administrator is God I don't mean this
in any kind of sacrilegious way but they
are all-powerful and they control
everything and so why in the world would
you go to all this trouble and all this
pomp and circumstance to have all these
different classification levels and then
put it on a computer where basically the
system in has full control over
everything and that's exactly what they
did
and so compartmentalization is this idea
of saying look through your processes
and say and say were my single points of
failure right do I have a single system
administrator that could mess me up or
do I have double checks on it you know
we have just even in my own company of a
very simple process for example for
updating our website no one person can
update our website there always needs at
least two people for that exact same
idea it actually comes from well the
idea is very very old but if you've ever
seen the movie wargames anything about
the missile silos there's sort of this -
- missile silo key if you're familiar
with that and the keys to launch a
nuclear missile are further apart than
one human's hands and they and two
people have to do it that's just because
if one person gets corrupted gets goes
rogue goes insane you have that backup
of another person so apply the same
thing to your to your to your computer
systems find those single points of
failure and put in the redundant check
whether that single point of failure is
a computer failure or a human process
failure so that's pretty much all I had
outside of the QA the whole idea again
is is if you want to really solve the
cybersecurity problem you got to tackle
it from the economic point of view right
you got to make it too expensive to
attack whether it's you know having one
little script that can take over ten
million websites let's stop that or just
you know having one person that you can
corrupt and steal all the data on the
NSA same idea I look at it from the
economics point of view and make it very
very expensive to attack and if you can
make it expensive for your attackers and
make it more expensive for the attackers
than it is for you to defend then I
think we're going to win this so at the
end of my prepared remarks I love to
have any questions and discussion yes
sir
[Music]
yes so so the question was one of the
ways to change the changed economics of
the taxes basically apply fine-grained
permissions
iein controls and the question was why
didn't I why did I not mention that so
for the purposes of a one-hour talk I
highlighted some of the more popular
techniques if you look at moving target
defense broadly MIT a gentleman named
dr. hon endo poverty every two years
sorry every four years they published a
survey the survey of all the different
techniques is three hundred pages long
with no more than one page per technique
so there are a lot of different ideas
out there in my own personal experience
I love the idea of fine grained control
the challenge historically has been one
of complexity you end up getting if you
try to deploy this in any kind of real
environment when you really try to get
down and do all these different
fine-grained controls it ends up being
very very hard and complex to manage if
you sort of look at you know kind of
example would be even firewalls
like some of the web application
firewalls they allow you in principle
you go look at the the programming
language they have extremely fine
grained control over all the URLs and
all the different parameters coming in
and so forth yet in my personal
anecdotal experience when I go look at a
customer's wife they usually have
company comm slash star and that's the
laughs rule because just gets to be too
much to manage
I believe so and I'm actually very
hopeful for it
speaking of MIT they actually have a new
operating system that is applying these
rules literally at the data structure
level and they've got some clever ideas
to basically automate you know what's
what's there and what's not okay thanks
for the tip the the comment was as a
company or project SEL for for
fine-grained control and they apparently
have addressed the manageability problem
all right thank you very much
other comments questions yes sir
briefly then maybe he'll outright a
little bit so I react in the right way
because there was a lot of different
error classifications
so if I may summarize the question if
you have this fairly the question is how
do you handle the trade-off between
security and the complexity and
manageability of deploying the security
particularly in a scenario of moving
target defense where you're introducing
a lot of dynamism so this one I'm gonna
get on a maybe a personal soapbox you
don't you the thing that wins is
simplicity so for example this whole
thing we're talking about and I'll speak
a little bit about what like what my
company does this whole thing of
[Music]
polymorphic operating systems that idea
has been around for thirty years people
have had the technology to do it is you
is a scrambling compiler I first learned
of this in 2003 I was Bill Gates's
technology advisor at the time and that
was the whole era blaster and all these
things where we're you know Microsoft
was you know really had arguably it's
sort of wake up call to to worry about
cybersecurity and one of the roles that
I had at that point was to just go study
everything going on and we found an
academic paper called epidemiology of
cyber attacks and that academic paper
used the mathematics of Epidemiology the
spread of virus
to basically make this argument I made
before of if things are a monoculture
and everything's got about we're we're
in trouble
so this is being recorded and not sure
alcohols gonna listen so I'm not going
to give the exact wording of the
conversation because it was maybe a
little more colorful but the the tone of
it was between Bill Gates and I talking
about this was alright great we have our
answer this is how we do it ok 2003
something like 20% of our customer base
had internet access wasn't but a few
years ago we were still selling on
floppy disks in a world of floppy discs
how do you make everything unique
because this it was this problem with
the mathematics and the idea was was
spot on but we didn't know how to how to
deploy it in a very practical sense and
so my view is the security technologies
that are going to work and get deployed
are the ones that are are super easy to
do multi-factor authentication didn't
take off until everybody had a cell
phone you could go by the RSA was
selling the little key fobs for I don't
remember when they introduced it they
were selling those for a long long time
and as a person who had a key fob I can
tell you it was a pain in the butt it
just was not a very user-friendly
experience and they didn't take off that
broadly you know compared to just a cell
phone based multi-factor authentication
and so I think the challenge for
everybody in the cyber security industry
then is how do they make these things
really really easy to do in the case of
the operating systems we now have it
just baked into the operating system so
it literally is one can
lying to install it and it's completely
fine forget afterwards you just change
your package repository to point to a
polymorphic repository and you're done
that's it and it took that kind of
simplicity breakthrough for these things
to become popular because you asked
somebody to do more work for security
and gotta happen
it's got to be built in
yeah it can be can be harder to debug
absolutely so I would say first order
businesses make it make it easy for the
for the end consumer the person actually
buying consuming the device otherwise
you're you're out of the water and won't
get adopted for pretty much for the
operating system debugging those are
very easy because you end up with
legitimate binaries so just as a regular
binary that you're debugging the way
you'd expect use GDB and everything else
for the scripting you end up debugging
with just the regular script engine and
you apply the polymorphism second the
one that still is very hard to debug are
some of the commercially available
network scramblers we've changed in the
network topology when something's not
reachable it can often be very very hard
to figure that out
and the commercial companies have some
tools for those but it is a challenge no
doubt did you repeat the question and
any quite other questions there's right
this one oh this one
got it so the question is would the
compiler generate the same saying
machine code in these two cases and let
me answer in two ways a great question
thank you sir
so in this particular example this was
meant to be a script engine
diversification idea so in this case the
the executing binary by itself would be
the same but it would be a different
different set of tokens going through
the tokenizer and the parser and so
forth right because what you're trying
to do in this example is stop the script
injection attack if you take this code
either example of it and run it through
a polymorphic compiler you would end up
with different binaries each compilation
would be different when you run it
through a different different ones yes
sir that's the whole idea of a
scrambling polymorphic compiler
okay yes ma'am so the question was we
showed the data for linux bugs does
apple have fewer bugs because of because
of their encryption or because of their
encryption so apple is always very
they're very secretive company so let me
talk more on first principles than
anything specific to apple because more
respect respect their their their desire
for secrecy fundamentally if you look at
io s the bulk of it is C C++ program
right it's basically maka last room next
I mean a couple years hence right
they've made it better
but it's a C program and so the like I
think I did I will go back to this one
so you know for those of you that might
know engineers at Apple there are smart
folks right but they're not magically
smarter than any any Linux engineer and
they're not meant to be smarter than any
any you know Microsoft engineer no not a
million times smarter which is what
you'd need to be and so the tools that
they're using fundamentally allow for
bugs and that was kind of the whole
point
Alan Turing's the halting problem that
everything is going to have bugs and so
I don't have any stats to share about
the about the frequency of bugs in Apple
products but I do know that they know
and since I just applied my Apple patch
this morning they have books to write
and so I don't think you know we can't
say that they are somehow magically more
immune than anybody else I think it is
fair to say that Apple as an
organization is particularly security
conscience and I think they do a better
job than most but are there are there
viruses on that Mac and iPhone oh yes
that there are other questions comments
yes sir
so the question is for the for the sort
of polymorphic operating systems that
are changing things like on every system
called change around the binaries the
question is does that interfere with
branch predictor or if I may generalize
performance in general so for those
systems yes then you have a performance
impact this or no not much getting
around that and the folks that are
working on them itself included we
basically take great pains to basically
use all the spare CPU cycles do it on
the secondary cores things like that to
keep the perf impact down to a couple
percent so you can get very tricky make
the perfect act very negligible and so
if you're running like a web server or
something like that you will never
notice you're doing anything i/o
intensive you will never notice but if
you're doing a flat-out spec mark you do
notice so that's part of the part of the
trade-off of you know doing these things
dynamically but you can't get it to be
very low overhead but look fundamentally
you're doing work and work costs so
there's the limit to how fast you can
make it yes
it depends on what you're doing I mean
since we do my engineering team loves
Ubuntu you not surprisingly we use
Alpine Linux probably the most just by
sort of volume for its you know ultra
ultra tight that basically for that
minimalism argument and so for kind of
more of the general R&D purposes of unto
is kind of a really good one because it
just they've done a great job with with
that distribution and then use outlying
for production because it's skinny right
right so the and the question in or was
just comment oh so the comment was you
know push versus pull systems
particularly with respect to automatic
updates and the advantage to a pull
system is you know when you break
yourself as opposed to getting broken
behind the scenes with or with a per
system there are pros and cons to both I
personally prefer pull but you have to
set that up in your devops pipeline so
that at the start of every pipeline run
you pull and then you run your tests
so the question was with Specter you
need polymorphism polymorphism each time
you compile doesn't help the
polymorphism every time you run would
help is that the right way - yeah it so
first if I back up there are actually
Specter is now a class of attacks and
fundamentally what you need for least
all the classes I'm familiar with
although I just did hear about a new one
that came out that I have not yet read
the paper so peace if I don't have it if
my taxonomy is not complete the the idea
is to basically match an attacker with a
victim right and so the real question
isn't so much when whether in that sense
the question really is when does the
compile happen and and do you end up
with two different versions if you're
ever in a situation where the attacker
can disassemble your binary and then
launch the Spector attack you've got a
problem right unless you're doing the
fully dynamic and that's why when I
think about the throw the market today
for polymorphic technologies the sort of
the the broad market of you know I
mentioned there's about ten million
servers or more that are running
polymorphic technologies of some kind
the vast majority of those are basically
the compile time you know just sort of
one shot every time you update you get a
new one
and they're not doing it on the fly the
customers that are extremely concerned
about security are doing it on the fly
and they're willing to pay the extra
performance penalty to
gentleman's question before and so right
now it's a it's really a customer choice
for the products that are out there
market maybe at some point they'll all
become dynamic once the most people are
okay with the performance penalty but
we'll see back in the go ahead and got
to you sir
so the question was do we have any
observations of which languages are less
prone to attack
I do like rust and check see I don't
Microsoft particular for doing system
level programming go is also another
popular choice none of these things are
panacea is and when you look at you know
rust and go and in check see in
particular all of them have some form of
unsafe keyword that lets you escape out
to go interact with the rest of the
world so I can't announce this yet there
are are was that yeah I have no idea
who's behind the camera there's a lot of
let me say generically there's nothing
to announce yet I am not making an
announcement to be very clear but there
is a lot of interest in a rust based
Linux but the challenge we have is kind
of like if folks are familiar with a SLR
that's address space layout
randomization it's a very good
technology it actually grew out of that
Bill Gates paper that I mentioned with
the block creating diversity but for the
first it was introduced in Windows Vista
for a recall correctly but for like the
first ten years everybody bypassed it
pretty easily because not every last the
allow in a Windows program was done with
a SLR so even as recently as four years
ago the Olay help dialog basically the
the dll that put up the health help
screens for office and things like
was not ASL art and so if you're the
attacker they just went there and got
all your stuff because you knew exactly
where it was and so it was only until
about Windows 10 when pretty much
everything became ASL art so it's almost
a decade-long effort to get that
technology to the point where it sort of
really became effective and I'd make the
same argument for rust and go and check
to see from Microsoft know if anybody
comes at you and says oh you know life
is solved because we wrote our thing and
rust will never have memory issues yeah
no not really but is it still a good
idea to use one of those languages
versus see if you're doing something new
heck yeah
because eventually it's going to catch
up and that's kind of the the idea
behind you know taking critical pieces
of you know America and frankly the
world's infrastructure like Linux and
re-engineering them to be in these one
of these languages I guess the one thing
I can say because I think it's public
the check see effort out of Microsoft
one of their design points explicitly
was being amenable to automatic
conversion from cnc plus plus so rust is
a little awkward to automatically
convert scenes check see is actually
pretty straightforward to automatically
convert because everybody has this idea
of saying let's take our legacy and over
time move it because it's worth the
effort but you know we won't really see
the payoff until we get to the end with
check see yes sir yeah there's pretty
clever the way they did it gentleman
named it's called check to see I'm sorry
the question was with check see could
you do the automatic conversion
conversion from C&C was plus
even with pointer arithmetic and the way
they did it not all look if you got
demented no and I've certainly written a
lot of demented
arithmetic code in my past but if you
just sort of take your vanilla you know
you know star star P plus plus type
construct you know just incrementing a
pointer those things are pretty easy to
spot in the in the translating compiler
and then you'd convert them over so
gentleman gentleman named David Hardy D
is the lead engineer on that at
Microsoft in you know kudos to them I
think they've done some really good work
there but again whether it's check C
Roscoe that's all about this idea of
let's do something with our existing
install base yes sir
so the question was how much work has
been done on setting up minimal
environments I would argue in the last
say five years a lot and darker maybe is
the shining star of all of that and it's
the fault Linux installation is out by
Linux you know that a little a megabyte
version of it and so this idea of you
know making things smaller you know has
really taken off in the Linux community
in particular Microsoft last year
announced Windows Server Nano now
Minister run a know at the last
developer preview was one gigabyte so I
think they kind of missed the real idea
there yeah it's it's yeah it's none
other way that I do my diets but that's
a whole different topic but but even
Microsoft is is has said oh gosh yeah
there is something to be said for this
mint
some idea and we're gonna apply it and
so they're working on it but having been
a windows engineer in the past even
getting windows down to a gigabyte that
actually was a very you know all teasing
at Microsoft aside that actually wasn't
impressive bit of Engineering Windows is
not easy to shrink oh yes oh absolutely
so don't so the question was when I just
do a standard Linux install and get a CD
or whatnot
you get you get everything and that's
correct you like Ubuntu just the
standard of unto you know LTS like
desktop download the desktop download
Ubuntu is 20 gigs it's big and so what
you know kind of the gentleman's
question about like what Linux you know
or we using in my company we end up
doing both like for sort of the
day-to-day just development just on
somebody's lap top or whatnot they just
get the big Linux you got all your tools
all that stuff in there well a lot of
stuff is actually useful for developer
and they just get it all not the
developer party on and have all the
tools that he or she is familiar with
but then when you go to production you
got you're running it or somebody might
attack it use the teeny-tiny Lennox's
there and the thing that made that very
practical these days is docker because I
can be running docker on my a bunch of
desktop or on my you know Linux virtual
machine my bunch of virtual machine and
I can be doing my development using a
tiny tiny
docker is maybe yes you so sorry I was
I'm forgetting my rules here that need
to explain terms since it's a broader
audience docker is basically a super
lightweight virtualization engine so
it's like it's like VMware or something
like that but ten times faster and so it
lets you run
on a Mac or a Windows machine or another
Linux machine a tiny tiny little
operating system and so you all
basically be doing your coding on the
windows a Mac and a bun too and then
your execution of the code is in a
lightweight Linux virtual machine a
docker container that's one of these
super tiny little Linux's then you take
that container as is and move it to
production so you get the same
environment from dev to staging to pre
prod to production so that really became
very practical in the last five years
and it's a very seamless experience
these days oh yeah that was kind of
answer was a a don't put it there if you
can avoid it but B or what kind of are
you a bunch of laptop or Windows or so
for a bun to it is the apt system so you
just do app to uninstall and then you
got to go the stop everything you want
off just kind of annoying but you can do
it yes sir
that's why it's it's easier easier to
build up start with start with Alpine
it's eight eight megabytes and add in
exactly what you need it's just the
easier way to do it I I personally have
given up trying to remove stuff and if
you try and do it in Windows yeah just
really doesn't work so and in Windows
you can't do things like remove the
vollis's the floppy disk support it's
sort of baked in right so the comment
was removing things from Windows is hard
but if you run cygwin on Windows you're
basically getting a little UNIX
environment and it's pretty easy to add
exactly what you want so Sigma is
another form of it I personally like
doctor these days better than sigmund
just as I get a true Linux kernel and
it's completely seamless I'm running in
my same Mac command line I'm using my
atom editor and I'm you know saving
things that github is all Mac and I've
got my iTunes running and all that so
just the Mac OS but then my actual code
is just just Linux no this is my current
current world yeah I yeah I've heard a
number of X Microsoft folks do do into
buying a Mac for some reason
not the apples in a great job on the
hardware if you use boot camp Windows
runs really well I can neither confirm
nor yeah let me not talk about that yeah
any other questions comments well thank
you all very much for a lightly serenade
[Applause]